[Music]
today our teacher taught us about a
place called Africa
did you say our Mama's come from Queens
over there
that means that we
royalty
you didn't love me
afternoon
that needs me a wife
even if we have to part you and me us
have one heart
[Music]
you every day
and keep me from it
oh you must ain't got no Kinfolk around
these parts all I had was my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
come oh
you're sitting loving God
[Applause]
thank you
dear silly we are more than just kings
and queens
we are at the center of the universe